Jim was like come on Nick Jerry suck it
up I'm like right right okay Zoe leave
this is uh jungle no TV no Blackberry
the Avatar movies might be all CGI but
these actors perform every single stunt
wear elaborate costumes and work with
professional trainers to make sure they
can run jump fight and even hold their
breath for over seven minutes we've got
a lot to talk about here
take it easy don't get ahead of yourself
okay number one director James Cameron
always goes for authenticity even if
it's incredibly dangerous to shoot it
wasn't enough for the actors to voice
CGI characters that were underwater they
actually had to be able to do it
themselves Kate Winslet managed to hold
her breath for seven minutes and 14
seconds it was brilliant and I was very
proud of myself and I'll probably never
be able to do it again that came at the
end of four weeks worth of quite intense
training most challenging for me was to
physically play a 14 year old girl
number two she really went through the
ringer for this film being a 72 year old
actor didn't hold her back from doing
the same rigorous training as every
other actor in this film she and the
rest of her castmates had to unlearn a
lot of normal human behaviors while
swimming underwater for long periods of
time sometimes their shoots would have
them submerged in water for over 12
hours learning how to not squint or
clamp their mouth shut both natural
reactions when you're submerged during
take after take in a gigantic water tank
she had to have the professional divers
feed her back to the surface for air
just in case she wasn't able to make it
up fast enough
number three imagine being held down
underwater with weights around your
waist not only did the actors have to be
trained on holding their breath but they
also had to make sure they stayed
submerged that's where the weights come
into play Sam Worthington really
struggled with filming underwater mostly
due to his own fear it's the hardest
thing I've ever had to do you're dealing
with the restrictions of free diving the
constraints of motion capture underwater
and you're trying to keep an emotional
Journey going while you're innately
struggling with the fear of dying
it's how do you do emotion underwater
without you know how do you not look
like a blowfish
number four we know the actors pretty
much do it all
ready and action every major stunt that
you see on camera was performed by the
actors themselves they had to run they
had to leave they had to fight they had
to do all the things that you see them
doing in the film considering that the
actors were also clad in painful CGI
suits and head rigs they definitely left
the shoot every day incredibly sore just
look at these massive leaps Zoe Saldana
had to do one of the things that I'm
always gonna take with me is the fact
that I was a part of a revolutionary
experience in Hollywood number five just
another part of the brutal physical
training the actors had to go through
when you hold a bow you have to kind of
like you know hold it this way but the
navi hold it that way the rigorous hours
of training in such an odd way left the
actors hands and arms super cramped and
sore afterward that was one of the
biggest things we had to work with for
her it's how to shoot this bow and arrow
another dangerous aspect besides just
generally dealing with weapons was you
need to have perfect aim so you don't
hit something you're not supposed to
luckily for Zoe Saldana I have really
good aim but her downfall after so many
hours of practices I can only shoot like
a navi I cannot do archery like a human
go figure number six yes they got to
ride actual horses on set but it wasn't
easy they had to do tons of training in
order to be able to ride bareback and
manage the horses properly also because
the headgear they were wearing they
didn't always have a perfect peripheral
view not great when you're riding a live
animal we also can't forget about Sam
worthington's stunt where he takes a
hard fall off his horse
ouch that definitely had to hurt
number seven there's a lot of
hand-to-hand combat in these movies this
type of martial arts the actors had to
learn was called wushu which is a very
graceful form of martial arts that I I
grew up to like after I trained the
actors had to do months of intense
training pushing through all the aches
and pains that came with the learning of
the new physical skill number eight
anytime an actual weapon is on set
always creates an element of danger
luckily for the cast They had military
trainers to help prepare them to work
with their weapon of choice they want
you to kind of be proficient with
weaponry and stuff like that because
regarding the rain Sam Worthington had
to be super prepped in his military
training as he had to do all of the
movements in the bulky motion capture
suit and helmet number nine let's talk
about the way navis move we have to go
through not just climbing rocks but also
how to climb through the vines Iran Troy
had some major stunts to perform jump
from space to space while also staying
true to the navi movements he might be a
hunter or he'll be a soldier they had
him step in for several characters
because he was one of the few to be able
to hit all of the dangerous choreography
in such a Flawless manner he was even
one of the amp suits that was being
developed Sam Worthington had his own
style of movements he and James Cameron
based on his ability to serve when I
started talking about flying the
Banshees and the Leon optrics like a
like a board sport like this kind of
athletic thing he was able to get into
it in a way that felt natural to him
while still maintain his Navi movement
which brings us to our next point
number 10. a lot of prep went into
creating the Navy's fighting style we
had to design not just the stunts but
also the movements that would be
associated with the Navies they only had
a month and a half to train the actors
so they had a lot to squeeze in they had
to design fight scenes specifically for
those movements to shine through any
choreographed scene that came off too
human had to be reworked which naturally
required a lot of takes and a lot of
patience it's a lot more difficult than
I would have thought we had to
constantly be on them every day about
how they were fighting number 11 even
getting into character is dangerous
every actor had to go through the Life
cast process which they used to design
the characters basically they had to
wear restrictive plastic all over their
face while another layer of plaster was
poured over them going through this made
it extremely difficult to hear see smell
and even breathe though a vigorous
process it was highly necessary as those
designs get scanned into computer files
to get made into what we eventually see
on screen
number 12 things got really method for a
few days we knew we were doing that
James Cameron wanted to prepare his
actors for shooting in an entirely CGI
world because we knew that ultimately we
were going to wind up in a fully CG
rainforest with fully CG characters and
it had to look real by taking them to
the rainforest for reference needless to
say it definitely wasn't the most
comfortable or safe experience for the
crew I took the actors on what I called
a sense memory Odyssey we went to Kauai
we lived in the rainforest for a few
days we cooked an underground fire pits
we drank water from the leaves he wanted
them to bring those experiences back to
the set the way they placed their hands
and feet when walking up a steep section
The Sounds the smells and everything in
between that could be utilized for the
world of Avatar Zoe Saldana said that
those were the most physically demanding
days of her life just digging and
climbing and muddy and especially
because she had to wear her actual
costume we're videotaping and we're
going through the inside of this jungle
we've got intense martial arts training
awkward left-handed archery fight
choreography talented stun people and
some major hikes through the rainforest
who else is excited about the next
installment in the Avatar franchise